hi et only et was with Big Brother stars
at Jeff Schroeder and Jordan Lloyd after
they announced they're expecting so I'm
three months pregnant it was really hard
keeping it a secret
none of my girlfriend's in Charlotte
knew that I was pregnant or that we even
got married yes the couple called off
their big destination wedding in Mexico
later this year opting for a Beverly
Hills courthouse ceremony instead I was
crying because my mind was on wedding
mode I was all about prepping for the
wedding I the next week I was going to
try on wedding dresses with this lady
and I was so excited and then it was
just like boom baby
this pregnancy completely derailed our
wedding plans I was like we need to just
go ahead and make this legal and so I
told him I was like let's just go to the
courthouse make it legal and then we'll
have the baby and then we'll do the
wedding ceremony next year for now the
reality stars are just a focused on
their new addition who they're hoping it
won't follow in their footsteps I hope
it grows on here for a long time but our
kids on there maybe you won't push that
without a different path you know like
stay in school and be a lawyer get it
get a real job yeah